the kick-ass over-the-hill sausagefest
franchise returns for a third round the
Expendables 3 brought to you by reruns
of the Rockford Files so the Expendables
3 all those old dudes that you remember
from the last couple movies returned
kind of and they're here for more
kick-ass reading more one-liners throw
backs to their old work that they've
actually done as actors trying to
seriously I keep saying kind of because
it's kind of like that ultimately in the
beginning of this movie kick-ass action
scene you know it establishes what the
movies gonna be kind of Finch Stallone
tells his entire crew to go
themselves and it goes and looks for a
younger crew yeah the movie that is
built on the gimmick premise that a
bunch of old guys are gonna kick ass and
they're gonna come together and fight
together like we all wanted them to in
the 80s it's completely wiped out is
completely gone washed away now we have
a bunch of young dudes and a chick girl
in the Expendables and all of it's rated
pg-13 Watertown Glory funny things in
terms of what bothered me about this
movie the rated pg-13 thing didn't
really bother me that much yeah there
were a couple scenes where I was like I
can go for a blood splat right there an
artery getting sliced like artery nope
stab them in the back of course cuz the
Bloods hidden you won't see the blood I
got you a pg-13 but for the most part I
still had a lot of guns being fired
bullets flying and dudes dropping what
bothered me about this movie is that the
second third of the movie looked at
whole one third of the entire movies
boring as he goes to find these
young guy that just goes against the
entire premise of the Expendables it is
conceptually that stupid the entire
thing that keeps the Expendables afloat
is the gimmick that it's a bunch of old
guys kicking ass it's the thing to
replace the old guys with young guys now
you just have a great be action movie
that's like other great be action movies
that aren't that good one of the guys
the computer guy I'd be okay with them
bringing him in on it like I feel like
oh we need one young mind among all of
us old dudes okay bring that one
computer dude that'd be fine he would
bring a digital element to that whole
analog guns blazing mindset resident man
why'd they do it end of this movie has
another exciting action it's you have to
leave logic at the door helicopters
don't move like that people don't live
through that and people can't physically
do that I mean it's the Expendables I'm
not going into this for logic I'm not
even going into this movie for
believable characters I want a few
things out of this movie full action old
badasses and references to
they're old movies can I get a couple of
those a couple of times in the movie I'm
gonna talk about I'm Antonio Banderas
he's in this movie holy what does
he play i honest to god think that
Antonio Banderas is in this movie
because Rowan Atkinson didn't want to be
he kind of plays Antonio Banderas on a
rockstar amount of cocaine what a waste
of his he's like the most annoying thing
in the movie I swear he is like Stewie
and Family Guy where he's like mom mom I
mean let me let me uh mom mom mom mom a
little background on Tonio bangerra's
has played this badass Mexican
gunslinger this pistolero on gray in
desperado that would make sense if you
really want to tone it back and calm him
down and you have him take a back seat
cool you can make him a sniper whatever
he was in this movie don't do that
movies not without merit though it had
some fun action in the movie and Mel
Gibson was actually really good as the
villain Mel Gibson looks like he had fun
as the villain in this movie about as
much fun as Van Damme looked like he was
having in the Expendables - Mel Gibson's
on screen you have so many bad shitty
actors in this movie Mel Gibson comes on
screen you're like oh all right so
that's act I'm not saying everyone in
this movie is bad I'm saying there are a
lot that are that's right this movie did
not lie when they say this movie is the
Expendables that's exactly what they
mean a lot of these characters
completely expendable the poster shows
you all these people yeah spoiler alert
it's lying to you not all these people
are gonna kick ass in this movie if you
want to get excited about the fact that
there's like a Tilian characters in
this movie and all these people are
gonna kick ass no that's pretty much
this the Expendables 3 has a couple of
cool action scenes and Mel Gibson was
good as the villain but they try to
shoehorn so many people into this movie
that don't need to be in this movie I'm
like what credentials do they have to be
nostalgic at this point as action stars
nothing whatsoever a lot of the acting
was bad so in the end the Expendables 3
yeah you're not gonna remember it in
t-minus one day yeah I've already forgot
Expendables is a fun concept while it
lasted I guess so the Expendables movies
have you seen them what's your favorite
two worst Expendables movies whatever
they are comment below let me know and
my campaign from my Latin reviews still
in full effect all the money that that
video receives from all the views from
you guys it all goes to the adaa the
anxiety and depression Association of
America in honor of Robin Williams
because it still sucks and I still think
about it and I don't like the fact he's
gone and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want is
or click right here to see more
[Music]